this is game tech where we break down
the tech that drives the games we love
and one of the many things we love about
PC gaming options now when it comes to
graphics it's easy to be overwhelmed
since there are so many damn options and
sometimes it's not even clear as to what
they do so today we're gonna make things
a little easier for you and dig deeper
into one in particular anti-aliasing
since digital images are made up of
discreet pixels any round or slanted
object is going to have aliasing or
jagged edges so to smooth out that
staircase effect you use anti-aliasing
it essentially blends the colors around
the edges to create the illusion of a
smooth image but this takes computing
power to perform in real time sometimes
a whole lot the higher the sample rate
or how heavy the effect is applied the
more taxing it is on your hard disk and
there are several methods of
anti-aliasing some less demanding on
your hardware some produce a better
image quality so let's run through all
the different ways we can grind out
those rough edges super sampling or SSA
a effectively forces the game to
generate a higher resolution picture and
scale it down to fit your displays
resolution it's as if you're
artificially increasing the pixel
density of your screen and the result is
a super fine image that looks real clean
it's the best looking solution but damn
does it bring your system to its knees
it's worth noting that the upcoming Xbox
one X will implement super sampling for
users on 1080p displays so you'll be
getting a pretty sweet benefit even if
you're not on 4k yet multi sample
anti-aliasing or MSA a targets specific
edges from pieces of geometry in a game
world and takes color samples from
adjacent pixels to project a blend of
those colors the illusion of smoothness
around an otherwise jagged object is
created the higher the number of samples
the better the blend of colors but the
more demanding it is on your GPU fast
approximate anti-aliasing or FXAA
is a blanket approach to smoothing out
an image it's essentially a filter
instead of analyzing each frame and
calculating geometry like MSA
fxaa applies the smoothing effect to an
entire image indiscriminately it's
faster for the GPU to perform but it
results in a blur image compared to
other methods MLA or morphological
anti-aliasing is an AMD technology kind
of like FXAA it applies a filter that
looks at contrasting pixels to smooth
out edges but still has a blurry look to
it although it's a bit easier on your
Hardware asmaa or sub pixel
morphological anti-aliasing sort of
strikes a balance between FXAA and MSAA
and both performance demand and image
quality it applies a filter like FXAA
with a little less blur but still
targets edges to create color averages
like MSA a temporal anti-aliasing or
TxAA
is similar to msaa but it's a bit more
efficient TxAA uses previous frame data
to create color samples in the current
frame it also uses temporal filtering
Tek for additional smoothness and it
helps reduce flickering or shimmering of
objects in motion that may occur in
other methods and we can't get away from
a discussion of anti-aliasing without
mentioning resolution specifically it's
simply the number of horizontal pixels
by vertical pixels on your screen the
more there are the better the games will
look and no matter what it's best to run
games at your displays native resolution
before applying any anti-aliasing for
the best image quality but at 4k jagged
edges are a lot less noticeable because
of sheer pixel density which is why it's
so coveted 4k means eight million two
hundred and ninety four thousand four
hundred pixels on a screen four times as
much as standard 1080p so I'd even say
anti-aliasing isn't really necessary at
4k
although 4k is performance heavy if you
want to know a bit more about resolution
and its relationship to performance
check out our previous video on why 4k
matters for gaming no matter what
settings you choose you'll have to
strike a balance between graphical
quality and frame rates that you deem
playable these are simplified
explanations of some very complex
technologies so if you want to flesh out
the discussion get in the comments now
there's many more graphical settings
that we're going to explain for you
so please subscribe to GameSpot for more
game tech thank you for watching and
we'll see you next time